your host cam Robinson and I'm taking
her from Chris waters he's going all the
way over to the other stage the lesser
stages I like to think of it mainly
because I'm here and I have a beautiful
orange sofa but that's not what you're
here to see you're here to see a
brand-new game just announced today by
Nintendo I'm joined by Cory how you
doing Corey good how are you to have you
on this day I'm doing really well great
to have you on stage thank you so I
remember the first time I heard about
the game Xenoblade Chronicles and I was
told I remember my colleague Mark said
oh yeah it's a JRPG it was like that
sounds pretty exciting and he said yeah
it takes place in this world which is on
the back of these two giant Colossus EES
who have been caught in combat for an
age and then they died and that's where
everyone lives so it was like that's an
incredible premise tell such people who
haven't heard his Amelie before
tell us a bit about it so the first
thing I want to say yes the original
blade on Wii was amazing amazing story
with Xenoblade Chronicles X this is an
all new stories okay so you're gonna be
creating your own character at the start
of the game however the premise of the
game is actually in that you basically
as an Earthling you know you have these
two warring alien species that are just
doing battle right above Earth we're not
really involved as earthling when is up
happening cuz we're in the crossfire
earth blows up oh wow oh good right
there are some Earthlings that make it
out they just get out in the nick of
time via their spaceships they end up
during the escape they crash land on a
planet called planet mira so [ __ ] oh
please a news story is you'll need like
similarity name really Sesenta play it
really is that name you're gonna see a
lot of similarities in gameplay so right
now we're seeing you know for fans of
Xenoblade on Wii you're seeing that arts
palette on the bottom yeah now the bread
and butter of that combat system you
know it is an RPG JRPG you're seeing
this auto-attack yeah although you've
got your arts down there on the left and
right - we've only got two on the left
and right right now what tell us a bit
more about those arts so what are they
how do they work oh the arts might be a
special like the left art right there is
a special melee attack like an assault
assault hammer the art on the right is a
shield so you can kind of shield
yourself up as you're playing and as
you're leveling up you're gonna be able
to get different arts like more ranged
arts
or more powerful arts okay the game also
lets you when you're choosing which so a
lot of the strategy from battling comes
from choosing which art in which time
because when you use one it's not just
I'm just gonna spam the assault hammer
every time you use an art it has to cool
down okay and so during that cool dime
down period you're trying to figure out
okay what's my next art gonna be or am I
gonna use to use my auto attack as
you're attacking you also have the
ability to you're gonna see here in the
next battle you're gonna have the
ability to change from melee to ranged
on-the-fly but before we get into our
next battle I at least want to set up
this scene that we're about yeah where
are we this look so beautiful what's
going we woke up the beginning of this
game we're actually playing like the
first twenty to thirty minutes of the
game right now just at the beginning our
character just woke up from slumber and
ARMA this female character here found
our character that we customized we
named him Cameron oh my god I'm so
honored but hopefully he does a good job
here so she's like basically as he was
asleep in this like sleeping pod chamber
she's like do you remember what do you
know what happened to earth do you
remember anything about this you're on
this new planet called planet mira and
so hermes her goal right now as the AI
partner is to bring you back to kind of
the earth settlement and you're gonna
see in the background here where that
spaceship or that where that where your
ship crashed and has now become like
this colony on this unknown planet mira
Wow okay so you're seeing kind of the
mist kind of roll away now and you're
getting up the first glimpse just how
beautiful this world is we're gonna see
some of the creatures kind of come into
the view here in a moment as it really
is gorgeous let's talk a little bit
about the world actually so em I've
heard the previous center blade there
was it was it was a large expansive
world but it was like segment a similar
structure this time arose
yeah I mean it's similar in the way that
you're gonna have if you're gonna see an
area you're gonna be able to pretty much
go there like when you're playing the
game when I was playing you know the
original Xenoblade I would just go I
might get lost
there's objectives there's a story
objective driving this awesome story
forward but I would get lost for hours
and hours on end just exploring part of
the fun of this game is just to go find
new places you're gonna have these
quests to take on that can take you just
way off the beaten path
of course I should mention as well that
you do have giant like MEK robots in
this game as well we're not gonna see
them in this demo today because we're
just starting out the game we did see
some great flying creatures there so
that scale has always been based on your
previous game as some of you guys were a
fan of like big monster is a really big
monsters we have to see lots of big
enough dudes in this game as well we we
are gonna see some giant beasts in fact
even here in this intro you got to see
some of these almost like dinosaurs
looking but I'll asuras tail thing going
on there and and you're able to
basically go up and challenge them right
now if you want to like they are here in
the world and if you want to take on
that guy you can grant any Semyon
enemies don't scale them so right now
the enemies are not scaling you're gonna
have level 1 enemies level 5 level 70s
all existing in the same game world
okay now that level 70 giant beast right
here we can see he's I don't know if
he's level 70 he's really high if we
walked up to him right now
fortunately he's not agro so he's not
gonna really mess with us if we leave
him alone
but as we continue along in the demo
you'll see that there are some enemies
that are going to often attack us on
site definitely heavily dinosaur
influence there is that something that
they the art team where I've gone
through the whole game or is they're
just really I mean the theme is just
it's this alien world so you don't know
what to expect as a you know as you can
see on the the ship here these are
humans from the United States that kind
of crashed here so this is all new to
them
of course ARMA your AI partner here
they've been here for a little bit she's
kind of almost a scout she was actually
just out and about doing her scouting
duty when she found you at the very
beginning in a sleeping pod chamber and
so she's kind of just introducing you
it's kind of a big change it's like if
you just woke up all of a sudden on
another planet and you're like hey
here's a here's a rifle a hand you know
a knife we got a like yeah I'd have a
lot of questions for anything so he's
kind of getting reintroduced into
society this new society this new world
here an MMO right now is actually just
kind of explaining to us that our goal
our objective is to make it to to the
ship and where she's going to kind of
reintroduce us to the kind of the base
camp ready so this is this will be like
your initial base you're an ish
kind of home city Terran where you could
learn the bartering system start trading
do you know people very much like that I
mean forget the name of the first turn
in xenoblade chronicles is this kind of
having a similar purpose real you know
there's this is not a game necessarily
that you're going to start neither was
the xenoblade chronicles that you just
start and understand everything
automatically it's not going to throw
you in a mech yeah very beginning of the
game so as you're playing the game
you're gonna be able to to learn more
about it what we're seeing here too is
this kind of a time station where you
can manipulate time we actually just
changed it from night time to day time
you can change it down to the minute the
reason you might want to do that is
maybe certain enemies only come out at
night maybe certain NPC characters are
only hanging around for certain quests
but if you leave it is it just like a
persistent day/night cycle if you there
is yeah you can actually see that in the
upper right hand corner there it is
about almost two o'clock and again on
that map in the upper right hand corner
that yellow marker is kind of guiding us
to the mission objective all of those
red dots just really represent other
enemy characters they may or may have
may or may not be a growth this guy was
just weeping he was just minding his own
business why did you attack him surely
as a card so you should know I just woke
up right when we sleep we want to level
up our character a little bit so we're
kind of being a little bit of a jerk
here but again just sneeze at me like
that
you're seeing us actually kind of take
different angles at him as well here
we're actually targeting him from the
front and middle but if we go around
from the side were able to target
different parts of his body notice the
terrain as well can block attacks
because his knees hit that tree so you
can cover behind obstacles right yeah to
some degree you can definitely use that
environment but really more of its gonna
be choosing whether or not you want to
be going ranged or melee melee attacks
of course are going might do more damage
up close you might get some bonuses yeah
but it does put you more in danger a lot
more damage from the back say and the
side attacks enough do they have effects
on your enemies as well absolutely and
it's gonna depend on the creature that
you're fighting in a moment we're
actually gonna get to some creatures
that have armor kind of plating on there
in middle yeah so it's not really gonna
be in the best of our interest to take
them from the front on now you can
target the individual body parts as well
so if there's a creature with a tail you
can actually like break off that tail he
can no longer let you use it to whip you
or something like that cool that's
excellent so listen a little bit about
the the size of the world how big is
consented blue chronicles with a good
long game is this a similar length and
everything or so a real JRPG can really
get your get your hand this game is
going to kind of have that same giant
sense of exploration again not you know
you may not be able to get everywhere in
the beginning there may be some parts
that maybe you can only get to like in
your mech or something but by applying
but in terms of scale it's absolutely
going to be massive so what we see here
is you saw that like little circles try
to align and we were prompted to push
the B button throughout gameplay the
battle if you push B at just the right
time you'll be able to get like a health
bonus for your character there's also
moments where your character will
actually be talking to you during the
battle she might issue you a command in
those instances if you actually do the
command she's asking you can earn
additional bonuses whether that be hell
there's some kind of other bonus so
right now we're thinkin a terrain Bruin
is very kind of lush and green are
they're varied like biomes different
terrains there desi desert areas I see
Ares is that kind of a part of this game
will take you all over the planet you
know you're gonna be traveling around a
lot of planet I haven't actually seen
all of the planet yet we're just kind of
focusing on the beginning but one thing
that we could do right here if we did
not want to go to the base right now we
could just take a detour and we could
just go wherever we could wherever the
terrain is going to allow us to go now
we might get ourselves in trouble and
come up against these like aggro enemies
that are level 80 or you know level 60
or something but but the game is not
like putting up walls telling you nope
you're not at the level yet you can you
can explore there if you want to go
there right now if you're watching at
home and you have any questions no
you're fine as Emma blade chronicles to
chuck them in the comments I'm actually
go and let the comment section open
right here so throw them in there and
we'll take one in just a second okay I
have another question it's gonna ask you
I want to talk about weapons right so
thinking guns weren't really a big
feature in the original Xenoblade is
that correct
so I mean what kind of how does the how
does a wack weapon system work is there
web for customization is there do you
just find weapons around like how does
it work in this so right now when you
start the game you're just going to have
of course the rifle and the knife and of
course one of the new features there is
that you're able to switch them on the
fly even in battle like just knife to
guns in terms of the additional weapons
you'll be able to find there will be a
lot more to that we just really haven't
been able to go in detail one thing I
did want to mention a little bit about Z
battle system is that you're familiar
with Xenoblade so whenever you use an
art you have to wait for a cool-down
period in order to use it again so that
system is still in place but what what
they've added is almost like this second
cooldown period so you're gonna have the
cooldown period and if you actually let
it cool down a second time so you're
able to use it but if you wait all the
way until you get it a second time it's
almost like you're gonna be able to use
it maybe I have this like bonus attack
power or you can use it twice in a row
so there's gonna be some sort of risk
reward scenario in those battles while
you're waiting for your system to
recharge we're almost at our base but
we're actually we're greeted with these
giant this is kind of almost like our
first boss encounter in the game if you
will and just to give you a heads up
where maybe underpowered severely
underpowered because we feel we might
die yeah well there are three of them
two of us and they are bigger
we kind of zoomed the camera out
manually a little bit ourselves just to
give us a little bit more of the scope
here but we can zoom in to this looks
like a pretty epic battle but afraid
this is we're gonna have to leave it but
thank you so much for coming on Corey
yeah just this an idea when who could be
expecting in our hands on sand though
Xenoblade Chronicles X will be releasing
in 2015 fantastic well thank you very
much for coming on stage